vamos a conectar los interruptores a los
motores y para hacer esto vamos primero
a tomar el cable azul entonces vamos a
tomar el cable azul y le vamos a cortar
un poco del aislamiento y vamos a
atravesar el cable por el interruptor
así que ahí quedó y ahora vamos a tomar
las pinzas de punta y vamos a hacer un
doblez aquí
y ahí está perfecto ahora que sigue
vamos a tomar el otro extremo del cable
azul y vamos a hacer que atraviese esta
parte de del motor entonces para hacer
esto hacemos lo siguiente tomamos el
cable azul y vamos a cortar este pedazo
y después tomamos nuestro pela cable y
cortamos ese aislamiento de ese extremo
siguiente paso hacemos exactamente lo
mismo pero del otro lado
así que tomamos el cautín y vamos a
calentar las conexiones que hemos hecho
entonces tomamos el cautín y vamos a
soldar
asegúrate de que la soldadura cubra toda
la conexión perfectamente
así que ya tenemos todas las conexiones
y ahora vamos a revisar los
interruptores vamos a revisar aquí las
palancas
muy bien funcionan y bueno lo que sucede
es que debes tener cuidado porque si el
cautín toca por mucho tiempo el
interruptor lo puede arruinar porque lo
puede sobrecalentar entonces bueno vamos
a asegurarnos de que eso no esté pasando
que el interruptor esté todavía bien y
si lo están
y bueno bueno ya ya tenemos nuestros
motores están en su lugar ahora vamos a
vamos a hacer la siguiente conexión y
para esta conexión vamos a usar un cable
verde baja vamos a asignarle el cable
verde a esta siguiente conexión y vamos
a conectar los motores entonces
al cable verde le cortamos el
aislamiento de un extremo y vamos a
pasar el cable verde por este agujero de
este motor
y hacemos un doblez y después para
conectarlo con el otro motor vamos a
dejar un poco más largo de lo normal el
cable verde porque más adelante le vamos
a dar otro cable al cable verde entonces
cortamos aquí el cable verde dejándolo
un poco más largo y también vamos a
tomar el pela el pela cable y le
quitamos el aislamiento de este extremo
y vamos a
vamos a atravesarlo por el motor y bueno
como puedes ver ya aquí queda bastante
cable extra
entonces el cable verde ya está listo y
bueno qué es lo que sigue sigue soldar
pero antes vamos a hacer una conexión
vamos a tomar un cable amarillo
y vamos a conectar este cable amarillo
con el cable verde
vamos a tomar el pela cable vamos a
cortar este extremo del aislamiento más
o menos que quede que queden dos
pulgadas y después vamos a entrelazar
estos dos cables entonces entrelazamos
estos dos cables
tomo las pinzas cortamos el exceso y
bueno ya queda súper bien ahora para qué
es este cable amarillo el cable amarillo
a esto lo vamos a conectar con uno de
estos interruptores del cual ya doblamos
uno de sus tiros porque necesitamos que
sea un interruptor de un solo tiro y un
solo polo así que bueno ahí está hagamos
la conexión ahora como doble el tiro
bueno fue fácil simplemente tomas tus
pinzas de punta y con ellas tomas el
tiro y los dobles pero ahora dobla los
que están en los extremos no dobles los
de enmedio porque los de enmedio eso los
vas a necesitar así que tomas las pinzas
de punta y haces el dobles así fácil muy
bien entonces bueno hagamos esta
conexión pero primero vamos a colocar el
interruptor en su lugar ponemos entonces
un poco de silicón caliente aquí y vamos
a colocar el interruptor ahí
pero ten cuidado de que el silicon no
toque los polos ni los tiros para que
así pueda funcionar adecuadamente el
interruptor
entonces bueno cortamos el cable
amarillo más o menos que quede así de
largo y ahora vamos a soldar las
conexiones que hicimos
toma el cautín y recuerda debes limpiar
la punta del cautín
vamos con el cable amarillo al cable
amarillo le vamos a cortar
un extremo del aislamiento que tiene
aquí
las cables y ahora con el cable amarillo
vamos a formar vamos a doblarlo y vamos
a formar un pequeño lazo
de hecho puedes usar las pinzas de punta
para ayudarte a crear ese lazo porque
puede ser un poco difícil pero ahí
después vamos a colocarlo de esta forma
en el interruptor
como puedes ver ya tenemos estos cables
en una posición a veces tienden a
moverse un poco no a quedarse en su
lugar
ahora vamos a tomar el otro pedazo del
cable amarillo vamos a cortarle aquí del
extremo un pedazo del aislamiento con
con el pela cables y vamos a hacer lo
mismo vamos a formar un pequeño lazo
ahora vamos a conectar esto al otro lado
pero bueno como puedes ver nuevamente el
interruptor se despegó pero bueno suele
pasar tiene remedio no pasa nada
y cuando creo que es el cable en el polo
del interruptor puedes doblarlo con sus
pinzas de punta eso te ayudará a
mantenerlo bien sujetado
y algo importante es que estas dos
conexiones no deben tocarse ajá es es un
poco difícil lograr que no se toquen
pero si se puede conseguir entonces no
deben tocarse porque si se tocan te va a
ocasionar problemas con el interruptor
y bueno ahí quedó entonces no no puede
ser bueno se salió el cable pero tiene
remedio vamos a arreglar esto ahí quedó
ya perfecto ahí lo tienes entonces bueno
ya tenemos aquí el interruptor conectado
y podría usar el tercer brazo para que
me apoye un poco con esto porque está un
poco difícil entonces uso aquí la pinza
de caimán ahora no baja no puede ser que
estos cables no se quedan en su lugar ya
salió este otro cable pero lo arreglamos
entonces ya tenemos una buena conexión y
ahora vamos a soldar
a poner soldaduras sobre las conexiones
sobre estos polos
como puedes ver
la soldadura que estoy colocando en cada
uno de ellos no se está tocando porque
yo no quiero que esa conexión se toque
es importante como te lo dije que no se
toque para que el interruptor funcione
adecuadamente y bueno ahí lo tienes ya
está esto soldado y entonces lo voy a
quitar del tercer brazo así debe quedar
como observas aquí y bueno las dos
partes que soldamos no se tocan la
soldadura en cada cada parte que
soldamos queda completamente separada y
bueno entonces vamos a colocar aquí un
poco de silicón caliente colocamos aquí
un poco de silicón caliente y para que
quede mejor lo que haces es ya pusimos
el pegamento lo colocamos en su lugar y
vamos a presionar por arriba por arriba
del interruptor presionas hasta que
quede un poco ya seco también cuidado de
no quemarte con el silicón caliente no
te vayas a quemar los dedos
muy bien ahí está y ahora una vez que ya
quedó todo esto en su lugar tú puedes
colocar más pegamento caliente sobre
toda esta área para que todo se mantenga
en su lugar baja todo tu trabajo quede
bien sujeto aquí todas las conexiones y
el interruptor se quede donde debe ir y
también que los cables amarillos no se
toquen